[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARTHI THYAGARAJAN: I'm
a solutions architect
with Google Cloud.
And to start off with, I'm
going to talk about what a data
lake is, how you would
structure your data
lake on GCP with a lot
of help from BigQuery,
and then after that,
Dhaval Durve over there,
who is a strategic cloud
engineer with Google Cloud,
will talk about how you'd
operationalize BigQuery.
And then lastly,
Tomasz Stradomski
who is also over there,
will go into detail
about how Ocado Technology--
by the way, Tomasz
leads up data
engineering at Ocado.
He'll talk about how
Ocado built out a data
lake with a lot of help,
once again, from BigQuery.
I know we don't have
everybody in the room,
but I'm going to do a
quick informal survey.
So by a show of
hands, how many of you
here have either built
out a data lake already,
or are thinking about
building out a data lake?
OK, I'm not surprised.
That's good.
So this term, data lake,
is thrown out a lot.
It has a lot of meanings to
a lot of different people.
What I'd like to do first
is do some level setting
on what I mean by data lake for
the purposes of this session.
And I think you'll agree with
most of these characteristics.
The first one is this philosophy
of storing everything.
And what that
recognizes is the fact
that we want to guide
the questions we're
asking of our data based on
the data that we can collect.
We want to collect
everything, of course,
within compliance restrictions
and storage restrictions,
but yes, we do want
to collect everything.
And once we collect
the data, our data lake
has to facilitate exploration.
That's how we go from raw
data to refined data products
that will inform us, whether
it's about business decisions,
you know, new opportunities,
operational efficiencies,
things of that nature.
And once we surface
these data products,
we want to be able to
bring a variety of tools
to process these data products.
Of course, this session
is about BigQuery,
so it'll feature prominently
in how you do analytics,
but in addition, we want to
be able to allow our data
scientists to use
Spark, MapReduce, Cloud
Dataflow, which is our
serverless processing
engine, all of these tools.
So with those
characteristics in mind,
here's a high level flow of
how things go from raw data
to the refined data products.
And this will be kind
of a theme, at least
during my presentation.
On this slide, we're going to
focus on the ingest and store
piece.
We ingest data from
a variety of sources.
We want to facilitate
batch analytics as well
as stream analytics.
And when it comes time
to store the data,
I'm going to say
right off the bat
that Google Cloud Storage,
also known as GCS,
is the ideal choice
for the lake itself.
And you're probably
wondering, hey,
this is a session on BigQuery,
why is he talking about GCS.
And that's because--
and by the way,
when Tomasz goes into detail
over how they built out
their data lake, you'll
hear that they're
ingesting structured data,
storing it directly in BigQuery
and doing analytics
with BigQuery.
And that's great.
We love that.
Two things to keep in mind.
The first one is that as
your data volume grows,
as you go from
hundreds of terabytes
to say many, many
petabtyes of data,
it makes financial sense
to lifecycle your older
data from BigQuery into one of
the archival storage classes
that GCS has.
This way, you can balance
cost as well as analytics
capability.
And then the other
reason is that you
want to be able to do the
flexible processing that I
talked about.
SQL is great, but once again,
you want to bring in Spark,
you want to bring in MapReduce.
You want to do
predictive analytics.
And for that, GCS is great.
It's a great central
repository that integrates well
with GCS services,
as you'll find out,
as well as a whole slew
of third party services.
And I mentioned, you know,
working well with GCS.
And BigQuery, as
you would expect,
works really well GCS as well.
For example, if you
have Avro files in GCS,
you can query those
files, you know,
with rich schema and
all of that good stuff
directly from BigQuery without
first loading that data
into BigQuery.
Now, having said that, for the
vast majority of use cases,
you actually want to pull
that data into BigQuery first,
because it gives you
better performance,
it gives you more native
querying capability.
And you'll be happy to
find out that import
and export to and from
GCS into BigQuery is free.
And the last reason to use
BigQuery and compare it
in combination with
GCS is that they share
a compatible security model.
They both use GCP Identity
and Access Management.
This has ramifications for
how you do access control,
as you'll find out from
Dhaval, and encryption as well.
So if you have a
compliance regime that
requires you to use customer
managed encryption keys,
then you can use those same keys
for encrypting and decrypting
data in both GCS and BigQuery.
So we talked about ingest.
Let's get into the other
two characteristics
that I talked about.
There's a lot going
on in this slide,
so I'm going to unpack it into
smaller, digestible pieces.
And once again, the question
that's going to guide that
is how do we get from
all this raw data
that I talked about to
the refined data products.
To answer that question,
let's break those refined data
products into three categories.
These are categories
that I feel, you know,
will help us guide
this discussion.
So the first one is this
notion of a data mart.
This should be familiar to folks
who use SQL data warehousing,
but I want to expand that
definition a little bit,
even though this is the thing
that BigQuery is best known
for, you know, SQL
data warehousing,
setting up data marts.
But a lot of
customers these days
are also doing Parquet
files, Avro files,
and you know, refining
data in that fashion,
and exposing them to both
internal and external
customers.
If you do that, you can use
Hive, you can use MapReduce,
you can use Spark on top
of those files as well.
And you can also use serverless
processing with Cloud Dataflow.
The second type of data
product is streaming workflows.
So you know, if you have a
retail e-commerce website,
and you want to better
understand inventory depletion,
how customers are
navigating your site,
you could set up QuickStream
capture, send that
to Cloud Pub/Sub, which is
our global messaging service,
and then you could use Cloud
Dataflow to grab messages out
of Pub/Sub and then
use BigQuery streaming
API to ingest that data
directly into BigQuery.
And what that lets you do is
with very low latency query
that data.
We're talking a matter
of a few seconds.
This is pretty powerful and once
again, BigQuery excels at this.
And the last type of data
product is predictive models.
So whether it's statistical
models, machine learning
models, you know, you could
look at the captured raw data,
figure out what kind
of trends are in there
and set up a TensorFlow model,
and then import that model
into Cloud Machine
Learning Engine, which
is our serverless machine
learning framework,
and train that with
all the training data
you've captured using
GPUs, TPUs, and then
deploy that trained model into
Cloud Machine Learning Engine
once again and do inference.
So those are the three
types of data products.
One thing I skipped is how
you do mining and exploration
in between.
So taking all that raw data and
coming up with data products,
that's in keeping
with our philosophy
of letting the data guide
the types of questions
we're going to ask.
And this has to be
an iterative process.
We're not going to be kind of
rigid in the types of schemas
that we will expose
to our analysts.
In order to do that, you
need an agile, nimble way
of doing things.
And this is where BigQuery,
once again, can help a lot.
So without having to
put a lot of thought
into the type of schemas
that your raw data has,
you could load
that into BigQuery,
set up a BigQuery data set, and
then your data scientists could
figure out, hey, what
are the types of trends
that this data has,
how can we surface more
production ready schemata
in our data marts,
what type of streaming
workflows can we set up,
and then also do trend
analysis to figure out
the kinds of predictive
models we can set up.
So to wrap things
up for my piece,
I'd like to go over an
example that kind of
captures all of this and
also includes orchestration.
So let's say you have a
data lake that has to pull
in a lot of unstructured data.
This is in contrast to something
you'll hear about from Tomasz.
So let's say you have
videos, images, speech data.
This is something that has been
opaque up until very recently.
So what you can do now is
send these types of files
into one of our serverless
machine learning APIs,
extract meaningful metadata.
So if you have a
bunch of cat videos,
you can send that through
our video intelligence API,
figure out what types of
objects are in those videos
and what they're doing,
store that metadata
in BigQuery along with links
to the actual files themselves.
And orchestration
is a key piece here,
because you're pulling
in data on a daily basis,
and you have to
orchestrate it so
that metadata magically appears
in a system like BigQuery.
So Cloud Composer, which is our
managed Apache Airflow service,
is a great tool to use here.
Cool.
So with all of that
said, let's hear
from Dhaval about how you would
operationalize BigQuery on GCP.
DHAVAL DURVE: Thank you, Karthi.
[APPLAUSE]
Good morning, everyone.
Welcome to Google Cloud Next.
My name is Dhaval Durve, and
I'm a strategic cloud engineer
in Google's cloud team.
So so far, we have talked
about how BigQuery can be used
to explore your data in a lake.
Now let's take one step further.
Let's try to create a data
model, data warehouse,
in BigQuery, and walk
through the process for that.
So how do we
operationalize that?
Now, first thing in
operationalization
is how do you ingest
your work flows,
or how do you build your
ingestion pipelines.
With BigQuery,
depending on your needs,
you have many choices there.
If you want to really
write simple workflows,
just loading data files, you
can use bq command line tool
for that.
If you want to do some
kind of transformations
but don't want to
do any coding, you
can use Cloud Dataprep, which
is an excellent tool to do that.
For more complex transformations
or more flexibility,
you should use Cloud Dataflow.
Now, first three
options that I mentioned
are mainly used to ingest
data from either your batch
files or either your
middleware systems
like Kafka or Cloud Pub/Sub.
If you want to directly ingest
from your application itself,
BigQuery provides
you a streaming API
which can be used to
directly ingest data
from your application
to BigQuery.
These records which
are ingested are also
available in near real time
for your users to query.
So these are some
ways how you can
ingest your data in BigQuery.
Now the data is
ingested, so next stop
is to talk about access control.
BigQuery takes a really
simple approach over here.
You can add resources at
organization level, project
level, or data set
level with BigQuery.
All of your permissions
inherit from top to bottom.
So if you add somebody in
admin at organization level,
they'll automatically be
added to all of your projects
and all of your data sets.
On the right hand side, you
are seeing type of entities
that can be added to BigQuery.
So first three
options over there,
users, groups, and
domains, can be added
to any of these three levels.
Public and authorized
views are only
available at data set level.
If you make any data
set public, that
becomes available to any
GCP user in the world.
So this option is
available when you
want to open source
your data, or just
make it available for
everyone to consume.
Authorized views
basically give you
an option to provide more
granular controls over how
your users access data.
So if you want to go
beyond data set level,
you want to apply table
level or rule level access,
you can use authorized
views for that.
So now you have set up access.
How do your users get started?
So once your data is ingested,
good thing with BigQuery
is, you don't need to
do any kind of tune up,
any kind of indexing or
sizing up your environment.
You can basically get started
just after ingesting your data.
What your admins and
your DBAs can actually
do to help your users out
is go to BigQuery console,
write some sample
queries for users,
share them, which will be
shared across all of your users
in the project.
You can make them private
as well, but sharing them
will start your
analysts much faster.
Also, BigQuery
supports standard SQL,
which is compliant
with SQL 2011,
so as long as your users know
SQL, they are good to go.
Now, some of the organizations
have these central teams
whose job is to manage
these curated data sets,
and all other teams or
other call centers usually
query those data and
create their own data
set on top of that.
Now, with BigQuery, you get
charged for storage separately
and compute separately,
and you want
to make sure that your storage
costs, or your central group,
doesn't get charged for
querying by other users
or other analysts or
other call centers.
What you can do
is with BigQuery,
create a central project which
will keep the security data
sets, create separate projects
for your call centers,
and they should use
different billing accounts so
that what querying
costs they incur,
it goes to their
billing accounts,
and your central group just
pays for your storage costs.
Also, Karthi just mentioned how
you can explore your data using
BigQuery and
Datalab, but it also
provides a lot of connectors
for tools like Tableau, Looker,
and Data Studio to
visualize your date
or run your reporting
workloads on top of it.
Now your users are
consuming this data,
so your admins need to
monitor your environment.
BigQuery provides a lot
of metrics in Stackdriver
itself to look at the
health of your environment.
I have mentioned some
of these are here,
which can be used by your
billing admins, your storage
admins, or any kind
of resource admin
to look at how your
environment is doing.
They can also set up alerts and
notifications on these metrics
so that whenever the
value of any metric
goes above or below
that threshold,
they can get notified for that.
Let's talk about compliance.
So from an auditing
perspective, BigQuery
provides mainly two types of
logs, admin activity and data
access activity.
Admin activity keeps information
about schema changes,
schema creation, data set
creation, table creation,
et cetera.
These logs are
available for 400 days.
Data access activity logs
are available for 30 days,
and that keeps
information about who
is accessing what kind of
data or what kind of data
is getting modified.
If you want, if you
have a need, and you
want to change how many
days the data gets retained,
what you can do
is you can export
these logs into Google Cloud
Storage or BigQuery itself.
And you can set your
custom duration over there.
If you want to look at these
logs on a real-time basis,
you can always stream these
logs into Cloud Pub/Sub,
and update your application
to Cloud Pub/Sub
to be able to do that.
Now your users are using it,
your admins are monitoring it,
so of course, they'll
find new use case
patterns and new information
that they did not
know when they built it.
So how do you optimize
based on what you know?
So when it comes to
optimization with BigQuery,
there are three major areas
which I would like to cover--
storage, cost and compute.
With storage, so a
lot of data warehouses
have SLAs to keep data
for X number of days.
That could be 100 days, 200
days, 300 days, whatever.
And after that, team has
to remove that data either
by building it in process
or doing it manually.
With BigQuery,
what you can do is
you can actually set expiration
time for any data set, table,
or partition, and BigQuery will
automatically remove that data
and clear up a storage for you.
From a cost perspective,
one thing I say
is, if you have already
loaded data in BigQuery
and you are not modifying
it, just keep it in BigQuery.
Because if you keep that data
in BigQuery [INAUDIBLE] table
or partition for 90 days, and
don't change it for 90 days,
BigQuery automatically charges
you much less for its storage
costs because it considers
its a long term storage.
Again, you don't
need to do anything.
It just stays there, and
you'll get charged much less
compared to how you will get
charged for active storage.
Also, try to use
partition tables,
because whenever you are
using partition tables
and you use the right
filters with BigQuery,
you scan much less
number of bytes
and you get charged
much less compared
to scanning the entire table.
Also, sometimes you don't
know how big the table is,
and you want to just get a feel
of how much your query will
cost.
Before running a
query, you can actually
schedule a dry run for
query, and that way, BigQuery
will give you some estimate
about how much it's
going to cost you.
So a good way for you to
just try before buying it.
Also, if you are running
same query again and again,
and I see that happening a lot
in your reporting workloads,
BigQuery tries to read that
information from cache,
and you don't get charged
for reading data from cache.
So BigQuery tries
to read on its own.
Now sometimes, you have
users who are new to BigQuery
or new to organization,
and you really
don't know how they are
going to work with BigQuery.
And as this is a pay
as you go, your charges
go up as soon as
they start using it.
And you want to make sure, you
want to control how much data
they access or how much cost
they incur on a daily basis.
You can set custom quota
in BigQuery UI itself
for any particular user
or any particular project,
and that way, they will
never blow up your budget,
or they will never
go out of the cost
that you had decided
for them to use.
Now, from compute
side, I always say
start optimizing your queries.
Make sure you use
the right queries.
And what I mean by
that is, BigQuery
is a columnar database.
So that being said, don't try
to select [INAUDIBLE] with that.
Try to use only
those columns which
you need for your aggregation
or any kind of queries.
Try to use partition tables
and write partition filters
with that.
Also, try to denormalize
tables whenever you can,
because cost of
denormalization and storage
is much less compared
to cost of join.
Also, as you might
know, BigQuery usually
charges for pay as you go.
That's the by default
option, and what
I mean by that is, whenever you
create any project, by default,
you get up to 2,000 slots.
And what I mean by
slots is, you can
think of slot as
a computing unit
that you get with BigQuery.
You get up to 2,000
computing cores
or computing units with BigQuery
by default for your project.
So what happens is, if
you are running one query,
it can take up to 2,000 slots.
If you are running
multiple queries,
that can also take
up to 2,000 slots.
So if you have more
important queries
and less important queries
in the same project, what
you can do is, you can actually
set those less important
queries and run them
as batch queries.
That way, they'll
get de-prioritized.
They will still finish, but
they'll get de-prioritized
and your actually
important query,
which has strict
[INAUDIBLE] will run first.
Now, you might be coming from
some large organizations,
and you might have very
large analytics workloads.
In that scenario, you can
go to the second option
that I have mentioned,
which is fixed slots.
A lot of the organizations have
very high analytics workloads,
and they can actually come to
us and buy additional number
of fixed slots.
So by default, you get
2,000, but you can buy up
to any number, and
that will be a fixed
number of slots for your
organization or your project.
With fixed number of slots, it
also controls the cost in a way
that you always know how much
your monthly compute cost is
going to be with BigQuery.
So because once you buy
a fixed number of slots,
there is no pay as you go, you
can run any number of queries
and you'll still get billed
for how many slots you
have purchased.
Also, one option which
becomes available,
and we call it
hierarchical slots,
is something that
comes with fixed slots.
And I'm going to give
you an example of it
in the next slide.
So let's assume you have four
projects, R&D, dashboards, ETL,
and ad hoc.
Bottom two projects
are important projects.
They are strict SLAs.
You want to make sure they
finish on time, all the jobs
for them finish on time.
ETL project is mainly a
playground area or sandbox
for your new users where
they just want to try things.
You don't want to incur
any additional cost
for the ad hoc projects.
If you buy a fixed number
of slots, what you can do
is you can configure
this [INAUDIBLE] project,
ad hoc project, in a way
that it uses resources only
when they are available
on bottom three projects.
So any of the projects below
have any slots available,
this ad hoc project can take
those slots from those projects
and start using those resources.
So that way, you can share or
prioritize or de-prioritize
your projects as
well in BigQuery,
but you need to have fixed
number of slots for that.
So there are some ways you can
optimize your cost or storage
or compute in BigQuery.
Now, before I ask
Tomasz to come on stage
and present his
Ocado case, I'm just
going to summarize what
we have discussed so far.
So as Karthi mentioned,
BigQuery works seamlessly
with data lake.
You can explore your data, you
can do mining and exploration
right over there.
Once you have built
your data mart,
you can centrally
manage your resources
through Identity and
Access Management,
and you can monitor
them using Stackdriver.
When it comes to flexibility
and compute needs,
BigQuery gives you a really
great flexibility regarding
what you want to do when.
So if you need more compute,
you can buy additional number
of fixed slots.
If you just need more storage,
just keep your default option,
and you'll be fine.
Last thing I wanted to
mention was, you can always
share with BigQuery.
And the way it works, you can
always share and calibrate
your data, compute as well as
your queries across your users
in your organization
very seamlessly.
That being said, I'm going to
ask Tomasz to come on stage
and present how Ocado
is using BigQuery.
Also, one announcement
I wanted to make
is, this session is
Dory enabled, which
is our live questions platform,
so you can go on your app
and if you have
any questions, you
can put those questions in
this session's questionnaires.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
TOMASZ STRADOMSKI:
Thanks, Dhaval.
Good morning, everyone,
and thanks for coming.
My name is Tomasz Stradomski.
I'm leading data
engineering at Ocado.
You have heard quite a
lot of useful information
about products that are
available in Google Cloud
Platform, and how you can
use them to store and analyze
your data.
Now I would like to tell
you how in Ocado, we
combine those
components together
to build our data lake.
Not sure if you have
heard about Ocado before,
but let me just
quickly introduce
to you what we are doing.
So we are the world's largest
online only supermarket.
We deliver more or
less 50,000 products
to more than 600,000
active customers in UK.
But what is important, we
build our solution in house.
For example, robotics
in our warehouses,
front end application, back
end systems, everything.
The heart of Ocado are
highly automated warehouses,
which we call CFC, Customer
Fulfillment Center.
So you can imagine that on the
grid of size of football field,
there are hundreds of bots
moving, carrying some products,
doing some operations
just to fulfill
orders of our customers.
But Ocado is not only CFC.
We created e-commerce
end-to-end solution.
That of course, includes
delivery systems,
customer center
systems, so basically,
everything we needed to
succeed in this business.
As you can imagine,
we collect quite a lot
of data from those systems.
And we use them to
leverage our business.
For example, we have
recommendation systems,
fraud detection,
automatic classification
of emails that is using
deep network, deep learning.
But this is just
half of our story.
So on one side, Ocado is
the online supermarket.
But on the other side,
let's for a second imagine
that you are a
traditional retailer,
and you'd like to go online.
This opportunity is called
Ocado Smart Platforms.
So the idea is that we
are selling our technology
as a service.
At the moment, we
have the pleasure
to work with several retailers
in Europe and North America.
To be able to start new
environments for new retailers,
we moved our solution to cloud.
And the process
of moving to cloud
gave us quite a
unique opportunity
to rethink and
redesign our systems.
And that also includes
data architecture.
So before moving to
cloud, we've been
working with some
on-prem solutions
like [? Oracle, ?] Greenplum,
different on-prem file
storages.
And it is a challenge because
you need to plan your capacity,
what data is most
important for you,
what to do if you
are running out
of storage, how to implement
your attention policing.
So we didn't want to
care about that anymore.
So we wanted to
build a solution that
is able to store all
the data we need.
Secondly, we wanted to have
the data processing so easy
easy that everyone in the
organization can do it.
In most organizations, there
are some dedicated data teams
like big data, data engineering,
machine learning teams.
We of course also
have such teams,
but they are mostly working
on toolkits, best practices,
and enablement.
And the idea is
that we would like
to enable everyone
in the organization
to be able to process the data.
And to do that, you need a
really simple and coherent
solution.
So we run a couple of proofs
of concept, and at some point,
we tested BigQuery.
You have heard quite
a lot about BigQuery,
but let me just quickly tell
you what was important to us.
So first of all, it's
extremely easy to use.
You don't need to
worry about DP tuning.
So you don't need
to maintain indexes,
materialized views, hundreds
of parameters, tune memory
structures, storage structures.
You just load your data
and you can query it.
In BigQuery, you
pay for two things,
for storage and for
querying your data.
And it depends on
the volume of data
you, of course, are scanning.
But it's quite transparent.
You have good control over it.
It's easy to enable
your billings,
and there are some things
you can do to reduce
the cost of using the solution.
And it has been
covered by Dhaval.
It works quite well with
Google Cloud Storage.
So basically, if you have
a lot of unstructured data,
it's probably a good
idea to store it
on Google Cloud Storage.
But there are some products
that you can use in Google Cloud
to extract structure information
and store it in BigQuery.
In general, we don't have
a lot of unstructured data,
so we are storing
everything in BigQuery.
So this is our main
data lake solution.
Maybe the most important
part, its scale is endless.
So basically, you can
imagine that under the hood,
you have the processing
power of Google data centers,
with both great computation,
colossal file system, Jupyter
network.
So almost no way to
exhaust those resources.
And the last thing,
quite important to us
is data locality.
We at the moment
operate mostly in EU.
That's why we wanted to
have our data stored in EU.
And this is something that
BigQuery gives you out
of the box.
You can choose the location.
It can be US, Europe,
Asia, whatever you need.
So we decided that
BigQuery is going
to be the brain
of our data lake,
but we needed a simple
approach of loading
the data into BigQuery.
And we tried even sourcing.
So just to remind
you, our applications
are running in the cloud, and we
use microservices architecture.
So those microservices are
doing some business operations,
and that of course
generates some data.
So idea is that we pack
this data into event
and send it to the cloud.
So for example, the
customer makes an order,
there is an event sent.
The order is picked
or delivered,
there is an event sent.
The payment is taken from
the account, event sent.
And all those events are
sent to the stream in cloud.
We use Kinesis at the moment.
Now, you may ask why we are
not using Pub/Sub from Google,
and that's because
when we started
working on this architecture,
Pub/Sub was not available.
OK, so all our events are sent
to the stream in the cloud.
And from there, we
stream it into BigQuery.
So we created a real-time
application on Apache Beam.
It's running on Dataflow.
And its main
responsibility is just
reading the events from Kinesis
and streaming it to BigQuery,
so this has been
covered by Karthi.
But at the moment, we are
using streaming approach only.
That way, all the
data from our systems,
the data is available in our
lake in a matter of seconds.
Why we decided to run event
processor on data flow.
To be honest, at
the very beginning,
we tried Sparks streaming.
It was working pretty well,
but we had two main issues.
So first of all, we
had problems with HA.
So basically, what to do
if your workers are failing
or master node is
failing, and especially
what to do to make sure
that in case of failure,
we are not losing any events.
And secondly, we
needed auto scanning.
Our workload varies,
so at some point,
we are sending
thousands of events
per minute, a little bit
later, hundreds of thousands.
And those problems have been
solved by Dataflow for us.
As mentioned before, we
are using structured data.
And to have a good
control over what
we are sending to our lake, we
introduced another component,
which we call Data Registry.
It's an App Engine
application in which
every type of the event
that enters our system
must be registered.
By registered, I mean the user
needs to define the schema,
so what are the fields
inside this event.
Those fields are
mapped into columns
in BigQuery tables,
what are the data types,
and submitted data information,
like event name, event group,
which we used to
route this event
into a particular
location in our data lake.
This is also our
data governance tool,
because every single piece
of information that enters
our data lake is stored here.
So basically, you can run some
text search to see your data,
from where it's sent and where
it is routed in BigQuery.
So let's talk about
our data model.
So as mentioned,
we have our events
which we call row events.
And what is important,
this is the private area
for the team that is producing
this particular piece
of information.
No one as an
organization is allowed
to read row events,
which are basically
mapped to BigQuery tables.
To expose this data to the
rest of the organization,
we created a kind
of data level API.
So we introduced so-called data
objects and derived objects.
So for creation of the data
objects, in most cases,
this is just a view
or physical table
that is refreshed a
couple of times a day.
Our responsible data
producers, so teams
that are producing
this information,
so basically this is how we
enable the whole organization
data processing.
So teams are responsible
for creating the views.
The views are combining those
information from microservices
by doing unions, joins,
deduplication, aggregation,
whatever makes sense, to create
a kind of business entity,
meaningful business entity.
To do that, we run
quite a lot of workshops
to show people how to use
BigQuery, demonstrate some
of the most important
aspects of BigQuery,
and teach them how to
process the data in general.
So data object and derived
object are quite similar.
The main difference is that
derived object may blend data
from multiple systems, for
example, order management
data with payments data.
So this is a kind of
data mart that fits
some specific business purpose.
And derived objects
we are sometimes
exporting to Google
Cloud Storage,
and this is how we make it
available for our retailers
to be downloaded and analyzed.
So just to sum up, events,
this is private implementation
of our data.
Internal API, data objects--
so this is how we are
exposing the data internally.
And external API
derived object, they
are also shared with the
retailers we work with.
To do this transformation
from row events to data object
and to derived object, we needed
a kind of workflow scheduler
orchestration engine.
And a couple of years
ago, we couldn't
find anything that
satisfied our needs,
so we created our own solution.
We call it Query Manager.
So this is the
application where you
can create a task like execute
a query, create a view,
extract some data
to Google Storage.
You can combine those tasks in
workflows and schedule them.
But at the moment,
there is a new component
in Google Cloud called
Google Cloud Composer,
and it basically solves the
similar business problem.
So it's a workflow
orchestration engine.
OK, so we have three levels
of data classification.
First is the type of the
object that I just mentioned.
So row events, data objects
and derived objects.
Second is business
or subject area.
So what is the content
in this particular table,
and do we figure out a number
of areas, this is just a sample,
with sub-areas.
So we classify all
our data that way.
So for example,
if you would like
to take a look on some
payment information,
you can find them in the
area payment details.
And the third level
of classification
relates to security.
We have three levels.
Public, so this is the kind of
data that can be open sourced.
At the moment, we
are not doing that,
but the platform
is ready for that.
Second level is restricted, so
everyone in the organization
should have access to
this data if needed.
And confidential, this
is a bit more secured.
That's because this
kind of information
may contain some
sensitive information,
like PII data of our customers.
And combining those three
classifications together,
we created a convention of how
we are naming our data sets.
So data set in BigQuery is
an aggregation of DB objects,
of use end tables.
And it has been mentioned by
Dhaval but just me repeating,
you grant accesses
on data set level.
So basically, you grant
access to every single table
and view there is in
this particular data set.
Let's take a look
on the example.
For example, this second
data set, order details.
It means that we
have information
about orders there, data.
It's not derived, so
the information are not
blended with different systems.
It's purely about orders.
And restricted,
so no PII inside,
everyone in the
organization can use it.
So this is by just taking a
look on the name of the data
set you know more or
less what is inside.
Yeah, so this is basically
how we are governing our data,
how we are loading
the data to our lake,
and how we are controlling
and transforming our data.
If you are interested in
building data lakes on GCP,
I would recommend taking a
look on materials linked here.
For example, article
or some quick start
guides if you are not very
familiar with BigQuery.
There is quite a lot of
resources, Coursera self-study.
It's a lot of materials.
And there are also
some related sessions
during this
conference, so if this
is something that interests you,
I would recommend to join them.
Just letting you know that
my colleagues from Ocado
are also delivering
two sessions.
So if how interested,
for example,
how we are doing motion
learning, just after lunch,
there is one session
about building our CloudML
infrastructure.
And on Thursday, there's
another how we use
AI to leverage retail business.
So that's basically all.
Thank you.
It was a pleasure to have
a chance to talk to you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]